sie war mit Spannung erwartet worden
Putins jahresbotschaft an Russlands
Eliten sein Volk schaut von zu Hause zu
welche Richtung würde er vorgeben was
dann folgte war vor allem ein Best of
russischer Propaganda eine Abrechnung
mit dem besten
ich sage es noch einmal sie haben diesen
Krieg angefangen wir haben nur Gewalt
genutzt und tun das immer noch um ihn zu
stoppen
russland habe den Konflikt mit der
Ukraine friedlich lösen wollen der
besten sei voll verantwortlich es sind
die immer gleichen Drohungen die immer
gleiche Erzählung Russland müsse sich
verteidigen
sie wollen uns ein für alle Mal
erledigen sie planen einen lokalen
Konflikt in eine globale Konfrontation
zu verwandeln genauso verstehen wir das
wir werden entsprechend darauf reagieren
denn in diesem Fall geht es um die
Existenz unseres Landes
nach etwa einer halben Stunde wird Putin
innenpolitisch aber viel Neues hat er
auch da nicht zu verkünden die Rede
sollte Symbolkraft haben aber an die
Symbole der vergangenen Tage aus München
Kiew und Warschau reicht sie nicht heran